oh my god hey guys it's katie from tasty
and as you know i am always down for a
challenge but today is extra special
because we are teaming up with our
friends at buzzfeed india hi i am aniket
from buzzfeed india and today i am going
to teach katie one of my favorite
breakfast recipes
[Music]
katie do you know any hindi no i don't
know when we have three lifelines to
help you through this the first one is
this or that where i will give you two
directions in english and you have to
pick the correct one the second one is
google it where if you are lost you can
just google anything i say and the third
one is i am lost if you are completely
lost and freaking out i will just give
you an entire step in english but i am
super excited i love indian food i am so
excited but also nervous for you but
also excited so let's see how it goes
all right so i have all the ingredients
that aniket sent me katie do you know
what we are making today i have no idea
what we're making to get your hindi
juices flowing let me teach you how to
count from one to five eight is one like
oh heartache two is though okay like the
dose is like in spanish three is teen
like a teen like a teenager four is char
okay like a charcoal five is botch oh
punch like a poncho so ache doe teen
[Music]
low
i feel like this is a really good way to
quickly learn the length
yes it's ha and no it's
that's it you're also saying cup so
dough cup of flour
so then i need a measurement and i'm
assuming it's going to be these guys huh
tablespoon teaspoon
okay i'm
i'm guessing that's salt night water
because i feel like we're making a dough
half a cup half a cup
going in
with hands
add more water if you need it okay honey
is water i forgot how do you say a
little bit
you can do this
did you already teach me this word
oh my god okay so a little bit more oil
okay
so
in plastic so it doesn't dry out which
is pretty standard
do you say hello
which is potato because i've had potato
curry before
i'm assuming turn on the heat and boil
uh is that an ingredient um
i'm gonna use the lifeline i'm gonna use
the lifeline because i don't know what's
happening okay what lifeline are you
using so i'm gonna use my google it
lifeline take rest relax is that what
you're telling me to do chill out
okay
till they're soft i assume huh all right
great well we'll be back once these
potatoes are soft all right these guys
are feeling soft and tender
but
mashing it with a fork
mashing it is this a dish that normally
takes someone like no time at all but
i'm very slow this would take me about
like 30-40 minutes
[Laughter]
okay so one teaspoon
garam masala which i have cooked with a
lot so i know what garam masala is
delicious
powder is lao coriander
no it's not lemon juice um
do you want to use a lifeline i'm going
to use a lifeline i'm going to use this
or that lal mirch either means fennel or
red chili powder it means fennel um no
no it's red it's it's red chili powder
dhania powder coriander
sounds like you're saying dania
chat masala but i have this chunky chop
okay half a teaspoon done um
the last thing i have here are fennel
seeds okay yep half a teaspoon
paste i see some ginger paste here ha ha
i love ginger oh my gosh
lesson
garlic oh yeah because we just put
ginger so i'm assuming garlic dough
i think you're saying two cloves huh
going in
we just learned done yet
leaves which we is cilantro american
cilantro
britain coriander
because that we haven't put any
seasoning
great
a little
i'll mix
okay so just mix the potatoes and the
seasoning i still don't know what we're
doing with that dough you will see
so
i think this is looking pretty mixed
together
take the potatoes and make balls golf
balls etc a little bit smaller than a
golf ball char ball banana five balls
okay char is not fighting
okay
team
jar what was five [ __ ] poncho poncho
bored nicolo pela nicolo born that's
very helpful to me i've got a board a
baila nicalo is it a rolling pin because
i have one here
ab atta liquor
i feel like i'm in school and i'm not
doing a good job
otto is half a teaspoon no atta is arta
i know you've said anna so many times
and i know i should know it can you act
it out the
ana
it's the flower it's the flower and also
the dough yeah and you want me to roll
the flower out
[Music]
i'm excited to eat whatever this is okay
rolled out
[Music]
put it the potato inside
and wrap it around huh does that look
okay that this is the problem ha aobisco
i'm just going to do something and then
i'll check in with you
because i don't know this is cool
the front part looks great i think
it's fine yeah let it go
[Music]
i finished my last guy
is that a pan huh i'm going to turn the
heat on this is feeling pretty hot
no minute i like the cross over here
like especially now a lot of people have
started using some easy english words
into their everyday hindi as well we
call it english english
[Music]
tale oil
just gonna move my oil so that it
touches it yeah i think it's time to
flip
hondo
although i paltered it and it might be a
little burnt
that's okay oh that's cute that's not
not that's not really bad you say it's
cute i mean parathas are cute they are
cute
oh my god
i think he's good i'm gonna take him off
again i let it get a little too brown is
it too cute yeah that looks no that
looks cute oh cute cute okay great
what's the word for cute in hindi
do you guys like go high pitch and
you're like piano it's cute
i think this guy is good is he cute
enough oh yeah yeah that looks really
good okay should we move on to the next
step
you told me to bring a food processor so
mixy mix
did you say nihao isn't that japanese no
i said dhania
danya okay coriander
i have a lemon here
mint huh
sounds like lee moon lemon
parachute
egg butter
we learned this we learned this
salt oil no it's not oil don't answer
that oh fennel seeds coriander we put
that already
i don't remember ginger ginger ginger
clothes garlic garlic
i basically failed but i'm learning and
that's okay i'm just learning yeah
hari merch are these peppers
[Music]
oh
jeera powder cumin powder yes yes okay
paste okay i have paste so ginger paste
half a teaspoon
i'm almost there i'm so close
water water water water water water
or
mix
there was all the pepper in it and it
hit me in a weird place
this is not mixing it anymore so i'm
gonna go try my blender
i brought out the big boy
let's give it a whirl
[Music]
yeah that's not really working out this
is as good as it's gonna get i am
surprised because i thought that would
be the easiest part of the recipe it's
fine it'll still taste good it's
basically supposed to be like a dip i'm
gonna show you this and you tell me if
it's a nahin or if it's a han
okay yeah that's a nahi all right well
sorry i don't think this turned out
right are we finished am i done
we've used everything
oh
almost everything
this mango pickle ah i'm assuming this
is like a dip that smells so good i
cannot wait to try it it is all done do
you want to see my version of the dish
yes i'm very excited to see how they
compare
let me let me just go grab it
i have my final plate do you have yours
i have my final plate you want to see it
yours is so different than mine that is
not what i thought it would look like
but it's it's good so yours is much
thinner and like mine would you could
not don't worry about it i even i didn't
get it right on my first time okay so
what is this dish called it's called
aloo paratha paratha is like a flat
bread and aloo is potato so this is
stuffed with potato that's why it's
called aloo paratha you can make
multiple different kinds of parathas but
this one is my favorite because it's
such a big wholesome meal in itself and
it's usually had with dahi which is
yogurt or achar pickle which is what i
asked you to get but i personally like
it with this green chutney because the
green chutney adds a bit of flavor and
freshness my chutney doesn't really look
like chutney it looks like salad it
looks like salad
i want to taste it i just ripped it how
do you do it yeah you just rip it dip it
and eat it rip it dip it and eat it all
right i like it
the chutney spicy i want to try the
pickled mango it smelled delicious
i don't know what's happening in my
mouth but it's delicious typically it's
like a breakfast meal but i could have
it for any meal
this is so good thank you so much for
teaching me no it was so much fun how
did you think i did i think you did like
a 8 on 10 now
okay so there's room for improvement but
not terrible and you got them circled
which is a great achievement circles
achievements guys thank you so much for
teaching me this recipe etiquette and
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you go check out buzzfeed india
they are super awesome subscribe to
their channel let us know if you want us
to do this again bye guys
[Music]
[Music]